as you think about under what condition
might you be successful recognizing the
odds that Jeffrey described which is
that very few of these types of
interventions are in fact ultimately
successful it was clear to me that two
or three things must be true the first
is I must focus my attention and energy
on the things that would move the
economic performance of the business in
The Fairly near term I'll come back to
that in a second and second there were
critical relationships that had to work
now one of the luxuries that falls out
of your life as you grow into these jobs
is that you don't have the luxury of
typically human relationships you don't
have the luxury to not like people that
are close to you that you work with you
just can't not like you have to make
that relationship successful so it
becomes a rather dispassionate notion
that for example in my case is the chief
operating officer the single most
important relationship in my life in
1998 was the CFO the CFO was an
established talented guy ten years my
senior lined up to be the next CEO he
wanted me around like a headache and the
only way I could possibly move the
organization forward was to convince him
that this was in fact not so bad after
all